the ultimate cure for poverty the real
cure for poverty is a good paying job
and too many of our programs don't
address that you can watch this and
other programs online at booktv.org
john reardon is next on book tv the
former citibank executive discusses his
departure from saigon during the final
days before the fall of that city and
his rescue of more than 100 vietnamese
employees and their family members
saigon was captured on april 30th of
nineteen seventy five
[Music]
good
good
good evening everyone if i could have
your attention
it's great to welcome everybody here
it's great to see a bunch of familiar
faces and great to welcome some new
faces
i'd say tonight we've got a real treat
for everybody so i don't want to take up
too much of the time because our guest
of honor has a story that certainly
reads like a hollywood thriller and he
should be the one to tell it to you but
let me just set the scene if i can
vietnam the height of the war saigon is
days from falling and a citibank
assistant manager a man who could have
been any one of us is given a choice
go home
and never look back
or risk your life to save others
what would you have done
well i'll tell you what john reardon did
he risked his life to rescue more than a
hundred friends and colleagues from what
certainly would be described as grave
danger
it was a daring mission
i think the details will astound you and
if you haven't already you need to read
the book
is that a good plug
hang on i'm not done yet
because one courageous man risked his
life
more than a hundred lives were saved
they're now here in america with their
children grandchildren all thanks to
this man
today we're lucky enough to be joined by
some of the people whose lives john
forever changed and in a moment we'll
hear their stories but first it's an
honor to be able to introduce a real
hero someone who embodies the real
ideals to inspire all of us
john
[Applause]
true grit and determination and your
selfless actions and we couldn't be more
proud to host this reception in your
honor and those who helped rescue we're
thrilled to have you here with us and
have your book here
they're all my family and such an
incredible story to have
you represent the best
our country and our company has to offer
and we're proud to call you a city
banker ladies and gentlemen it's my
privilege to introduce mr john
thank you very much i appreciate that
i think they're going to let me take
over
okay
[Applause]
thank you michael very much and thank
you to citibank and and jennifer lowry
am i pronouncing your name correctly
uh we'd like to get it exactly right
lowney
thank you and uh andrea ligani i believe
he is here way back there waving andrea
thank you very much all of you and all
of the
employees and staff of citibank who've
made this evening possible my gratitude
indeed i'd also like to do just a couple
other thank yous to my publisher public
affairs uh peter osnos would you raise
your hand your way out there even higher
peter
peter rossos is the publisher
and founder of
public affairs publishing company and
he's here tonight with david steinberg
who's the
ceo is that the right title david
that hand was
was the was the top dog
and um
clyde brittle is i don't know if clive
is here he's the president of public
affairs but because of public affairs
this thing has happened for me they got
a hold of
me very early on after the cbs 60
minutes program and taught me about the
publishing business as much as they
needed to
and
filled me full of ideas and goals and
and
told me if i didn't succeed i'd be in
big trouble so so far i'm i'm told by
peter that i'm i did pretty well
and i hope that goes on
and i'd like to do a special thanks to
the cbs management who filmed here today
for i think it's called cbs morning show
i don't know which day they're going to
show it but once they put it out to me
i'll put it on my website and if you
have a book or get one you'll see the
website address on the back so please
stay tuned for that
and um
shahar baron is is he here tonight
shahar is another ham waving back there
he's the producer who
uh because of tom krause and because
marcus broccoli uh i i got to meet the
cbs people and this thing went rolling
like a snowball downhill and so far
we're still standing and a great thanks
to my agent uh
amanda
urban who's the
partner at icm here in new york
and a great
thanks to all the fncb staff who agreed
to be present here tonight either from
saigon branch or ultimately new york
twin is the first one he was our senior
manager in vietnamese staff and saigon
and the man i turned the bank over to
and he ran with it and i'd had a hard
time getting it back and i don't think i
ever did i got him out of the country
anyway
and uh our head personnel officer mrs
cook is right next to him if you raise
your hand mrs cooks everyone knows you
and the head teller chi
and
many of our family members here tonight
and then the big s-u-s not suv but s-v-p
svp
in
new york
rick rush who is my training director 45
years ago
and he did a great job i think and then
and then tom krause who never let go of
the story and called me two years ago
and said john i've got somebody you've
got to talk to
and that was marcus barackley who was a
former um
editor of the um washington post
and tom's wife is here somewhere else
kay who has also been so helpful in
working with all of this events and got
me speaking in message in new hampshire
pardon me sometime in may
say something about what happened
just before we left
vietnam and
the main thing that happened was i got a
telephone call very rudely interrupted
my day
for mr tom krause and peter howell and
he is out there he's right here would
you raise your hand peter put up both of
them in fact as they were on the other
end of that phone giving me a hard time
and i argued my best but lost every
battle and was told if i didn't do it
they'd send somebody else in
and i just didn't want to be replaced
quite at that time
so
um as the day moved on the staff
cooperated beautifully they did not
shanghai me or tie me to the post and
say you're going to be
a little bit of a
chip to get the bank to do what we want
they worked very closely with citibank
new york and hong kong which was our
regional officer and they let me go
peacefully the next day when that bank
plane came in and we couldn't get any of
the vietnamese staff on board because
they didn't have papers to leave and all
of this was very sudden
but
and they worked all day long helping me
burn records and travelers checks and
safety paper and
uh
i was very afraid that the fire
department would show up or the police
or the army or some such organization
but luckily they were paying attention
to other things at that time in vietnam
and that distraction was a bit helpful
um
halfway through that afternoon of april
3rd the day that the famous call came
from these young vps in new york one
here and one here
i was sitting at the telex communicating
with somebody i don't think it was a
friend i think it was either citibank
new york or citibank hong kong and
suddenly the telex paper shot up and all
this white space came out it was like
it had a run on paper and then in red
across the bottom of the telex paper was
uh john reardon you're wanted by the u.s
ambassador graham martin over at the
embassy right now and i typed in kind of
meekly you know i think this may be
misdirected i don't think it's me you're
talking about
and then they said get over here now is
the next line so i went downstairs got
in the bank car went over there the
gates of the of the embassy opened the
marines saluted and i thought oh i may
be in deep trouble here and uh because
the embassy already heard of our plans
from a little private meeting that the
other two bankers of b of a and chase
and i had in in the morning with the uh
economics out of shea so word had gotten
to the embassy and uh somebody pushed a
button in the elevator and up to the
fifth floor i popped there was one more
floor there to keep the rockets out i
think so that's why the ambassador was
on the fifth floor and i
walked into this room and i think it was
not as far back as that exit sign back
there but it was a huge room it was much
wider than the space we're in at the
moment
and there was this little gray-haired
man kind of like what i look like here a
little taller than me
standing in the corner and he said oh
here's mr reardon from fncb saigon the
manager of the branch and
he is going to close his bank and he's
got a pan am 747 jumbo jet coming into
town city airport tomorrow and he's
going to take all his staff and their
immediate families
out of saigon and
off and out of the country
and i said yes mr ambassador that's
right those are my orders and he said
well mr reardon i want you to cancel
that plane and i want you to come over
and have dinner with mrs martin and me
tonight at uh our embassy villa and i
said
mr ambassador i hope i can get a rain
check on that but i'm going to be
closing the bank tomorrow and the plane
is coming in and i take orders from
citibank via new york and he said
something that shouldn't be repeated
here so i won't and then he went over
and he did this washing of his hands
kind of a pontius pilot act as i know it
from my christian background and
he said i wash my hands of all you
bankers and the chase manager was there
and the bfa manager was there and 50
other people who looked like all of you
except
until he started speaking about me
everybody was facing the other direction
so all i saw was the back of these suits
and they were all black or blue suits
and when they turned around i knew three
of the people in that audience and the
rest of them were spies or spooks or
politicos or whatever they were but they
weren't common people that i had met
and uh he said it is my opinion that you
bankers are precipitating the fall of
south vietnam
and you will get no help from the united
states government or from this embassy
or from me
and
then he stopped and he said now get the
hell out of here like that and their
room evaporated the next thing i know i
was out on the street getting into the
bank car to get back to the bank and
continue on with what was happening and
the next day that plane came in i was
the only fncb
officer or person on that plane and
there's the little finger that i get
once in a while so thank you very much i
hope you'll find out what happened later
and how we got all
right now
well
done i get another turn this is really
nice
i'd like to introduce uh each person
here and then let them have a few
moments to uh or minutes really to make
whatever comments they would like to
do i need to keep it this can you hear
me just as well oh i can sit down too
wonderful so this is mr twin and he was
the senior officer of the vietnamese
staff and he was the one i turned it
over to after we wrestled and fought and
burned travelers checks and safety paper
and things like that
and
maybe you'd like to begin and then i'll
move on to mrs kook
well you know
when john and i kind of
stood before the telex machine
and with
the instructions from her office that
you know
we did we have enough money
if we do and we just pay off all the
depositors
get get the loans back and get the heck
out of the country because we are
closing
and
so i mentioned that no you know i think
i don't think we can do that because
the
central bank that's the national bank of
vietnam
would not allow us to do that if you
close it right now i think that you know
they're going to precipitate
uh
chaos in the city
so that was i think it was
the first of april the april full day
and
so so but you know uh but what we did
was we
uh
decided was just to
um
call as many loans as we could
as well as not to accept any more
deposit
from
uh from the depositors
but uh in the meantime
so these things you know uh happen
uh and created all the issues for me
when john was louis uh had slept
and at that point i think that people
just coming in with
lots of vietnamese psjas
and they said they wanted to put in
their account because
they wanted to get those deposit when
they get out of the country
so i said no no no no we we cannot take
any more of this deposit you know i
think that you need
these you know just to
uh buy something buy gold buy dollars i
didn't think you know because i don't
think that you should put in the bank
anymore
and so they asked me are you guys you
know trying to get away from here close
the bank and get out of the country i
said no no you know we have the central
bank to concern you know we open under
the law of the
center bank and we cannot do that
so i think that you know
but you know people just left the money
there on the counter and they left so i
think that poor chi has to
counter them all and put in a vault and
officially lock into the
the book
but
for me i think that personally
what impressed me
is that you know let me speak a little
bit about citibank
the reason that i last saw so long at
citibank because of the appreciations
for
my friend here
john
but also i think appreciation for the
bank because
i think being a small brand
i think at the highest level i think
that we don't have more than 50 or 60
million dollars in in assets
when we left i think it we reduces to
something like
10 million dollars in asset that's
including of a million plus of our
capital
so it's a tiny amount of money
but the bank
spent no effort
in trying to get us out of the country
as many as we could and i think that you
know as
opposed to three american banks
in a country
bang america chase
who were
open
five years six years earlier than than
we did
they
have more personnel
more asset and than us
but
they had no plan at all of getting all
of their
stop
members and their families immediate
families out of the country except the
city bank
so
my job during the last month in the
country was to
work with
our senior
managers in
outside the country at that time my
muktai was sitting in hong kong and i
think that you know i also talked with
rick rush
when was there and we were talking about
the
preparations to evacuate the
uh the the staff
uh i think that you wouldn't
see much of those details in the in the
book
uh the thing
is that you know i
appreciate what the bank was doing for
me
and for our staff
and i
truly appreciate that
and i got a kick out of receiving a
personal
uh telex from juan tristan at that time
he was saying that he was unbe
on behalf of the
board
and as a fletcher alumnus he wanted to
search to
to me to take care of the well-being of
the staff first
so i think that you know when the
chairman of the bank and telling me you
know i don't care about
the asset of the bank but you know took
good care of your staff
that
is something that impressed in my mind
and
that's what i appreciate
so much of being part of
the city bank
as well as being part of the event today
[Applause]
now mrs kook can you hear me okay i
don't know if i'm coming yes thank you
um mrs cook who's our head personnel
officer i use always called her the
union leader but we didn't have a union
there
stood up for everyone quite well
mrs coop your thoughts or observations
uh my name is goof family
back then is my family cook the fire
family name go first
and
first i have to say if john didn't come
back from hong kong to take us out i
wouldn't be sitting here today
i appreciate and grateful for him to him
forever
and also to citibank
as a personal administrator
i knew a few months ahead
that the bank had planned to take us out
like i was
instructed to put personnel record on
microfiche and sent to hong kong
regional office and
make a list of family and immediate
family members and contact information
then
i think
before the international staff were
ordered to leave sign on
i would told to pay separate pay to own
staff
you know this is a good and a bad thing
like you have something to lean on in
case
but also
they said now you pay someone pay and
the international staff left so
what happened to us
while the bank going to deserters
so well a sense of despair
and worry and
and
chaotic
and
a lot at that time plus what's going on
here in the outside like the north
province starts
falling into the north vietnamese
and you see the exodus of people moving
south and children and people die in the
sea trying to escape so it's really we
all worry worry so much
and
then the international stop left
john was the credit officer of the bank
so most of us report to the operation
officer it was bill walker at that time
and the day i think it about this time
in april
he came in and said i got to leave i
hate to leave you guys behind but i was
ordered to leave so i will take my wife
and my son and leave saigon today
and after that june was in charge of the
french everything was quiet everything
everybody worried but nothing happened
until the day john came back
and
i remember it was a monday and it was a
holiday in vietnam
and we were told to dream contact a few
of us and then we have like just like a
group leader and we contact the other
family to get to john villa that night
but we were told you leave with no
luggage
we're just like you go to work
mrs cook could we leave it right there
because we don't want to tell them the
whole story
thank you very much
and she
she was our head teller
and she can tell a tale right now
i don't know much about
you always start out
so everything was kept secret from us
so
we didn't know until the last minute
that we have to leave everything behind
our
parents or our house
and
i was
happy very happy when john came back
i want to say
express my gratitude to john for risking
his life
to save us
and
also to citibank for sponsoring us
to
come to the u.s
and have a good life here
thank you
[Applause]
and then we have this handsome trainee
professor boss of mine from 45 years ago
rick rush svp of the asia pacific
division in 1975.
well the i do have a picture of john
sitting down on the job but that's
not going to be sitting next to me
maybe just a little bit about what was
going on the boring end of the business
in head office at that time you know we
can all recall that this was the period
of time when the domino theory was being
widely distributed in terms of the press
view of what's going on and obviously
people here were very worried if vietnam
went then clearly laos
and cambodia were gone there were
insurrections in the philippines in
thailand in malaysia in indonesia where
would it end there was a lot of concern
about that
and walt was very much on top of it
walt
had a friend in washington named
kissinger who he talked to on a regular
basis
and it was the result of a conversation
there that caused the telephone call
that
tom and pete got that then got
transmitted on to john
walt was a decisive guy but he was also
very very committed to the city bankers
all over the world and the
instructions he gave were very clear
that everything was to be done no
expense or effort was to be spared to
get the staff out
and he backed that up with with action
because he called juan tripp
at pan am and got a commitment to make
planes available any time we called and
said we needed him he called his friends
in the shipping business
and so he was clearly on board
he was doing his job what were the rest
of us doing well john said i was the
division head i really wasn't the only
division head because the the head of
the international
business at that time was george voida
who
had come up through the bank system in
asia and was relatively new in that
position and he had different ideas
about organizing so
the environment that tom and pete and i
worked in was that there were four
division heads for asia there was
bert davidson in tokyo for north asia
there was sam easter brooks in the
philippines for
east asia there was bill farnsworth in
bangkok where i'd come from who was in
charge of south asia and then we in new
york were supposed to be the sort of
coordinators and
and make things work together
and it did work pretty well george was
an interesting guy and it actually was a
concept that
got the decision-making down much closer
to where the action was
uh it just made life a little more
complicated for some people but one of
the things that the division heads were
working on clearly the evacuation and
then a lot of work on how to deal with
the
placement of the staff
uh how the settlements would be made
thanks
to ms cook we had the personnel records
so we know the skills of people and
there was group there was a group put
together good personnel officers to deal
with that
we also were worried
about the the side effects of it because
clearly if we left vietnam there were a
lot of countries in asia where that
would raise some questions and so the
division heads put together
a common approach to go around to all
the central banks and ministries of
finance explain what we were doing why
we did it
and assure them that we were not
abandoning asia that this was our
commitment to asia was strong
that we wanted to be there to take care
of our customers and that we would not
this was just something we had to do
we also were worried about the managers
in the countries because with the
newspapers really pushing on this
domino theory thing it was hard to
you know have a grasp as to how you
ought to
put that together and so pete howell
was tasked with putting together a
seminar that we ran for all the
senior officers
pete got some of his buddies chalmers
johnson from berkeley who was the
reigning expert at that time on japan
and north asia and ezra vogel who at
yale who was just starting his book on
deng xiaoping
who else did we have pete i don't
remember i can't remember
but he got out he doesn't
is our
expert and he got a bunch of people
together the seminar was really i think
well received and and went over well it
gave a little perspective for
the the managers to think about uh in in
doing that
uh the uh and it was supported by walt
um
rick do you think we could leave it
there for now and then may i say a
second book may i say one thing about
one
person that's sitting here because this
we should not forget
uh the part of the success in asia of
course was that we
hired very bright motivated selfless
people
that were locals to the countries and
developed them into the managers etc and
probably the best example of that is chu
yen wong who is here
and he will be in the history books of
citibank forever
because cheon is the only country
manager who ever turned the lights out
on a country and then went back and
turned the lights back on when it was
safe
and maybe we could switch over to tom
krause and that telephone call and from
whatever else yes i will be very brief
and
it must have been a duet
pete howell over here who should be up
here also
and i as based on the information we
were getting
fairly heavy duty information back here
and john was getting
much less in vietnam they had no idea
really
how bad things were
and uh so when we called him that
fateful day he was resisting just about
everything we suggested i think it was
more than a suggestion but nevertheless
let's leave it at that
it
i i think i will pause and say that the
book is a page turner
uh it's it's a tribute to john it's a
tribute to the vietnamese staff
and it's a tribute to citibank and uh
it's it's a great read
i think everyone's going to get a copy
of it
and i encourage you to run home and
start plowing you don't have to plow
it's an easy read
[Laughter]
but it's our back here we we had a
we had a flurry of activity but nothing
we did really had much impact because
ultimately it was john who made things
happen we had planes we had ships
all heading to vietnam but they all left
more or less empty and not until john
pulled his
his
adoption trick
did everything fall into place so
thank you tom
and i have one more minute thanks i just
would like to mention the name mike
mctighe because he was my boss who took
off for the trip the skiing trip in
switzerland left me in charge but he's
the one also that asked me to out for
dinner after the big boss george voider
came and said you will not go back and
we all swore yes
and um
mctighe was the one who made the case
for me that somebody had to go back and
they had taken his passport away and i
still had mine so it wasn't much of a
choice at that point in time
i would i would also like to say if i've
got 10 seconds left there are three
people maybe here leslie stahl
maria maria marie arana and um
i saw marie's hand out there and craig
whitney are you here craig's in the back
there from the new york times maria is a
famous author and um
advisor to the library of congress
and uh leslie stahl uh i think you might
know from cbs 60 minutes
they were extremely helpful they all did
blurbs for the book and
i think that's the right word now i kept
calling them blobs but
john marcus is back there
marcus could you raise your hand i'd
like to meet you he's the missing the
missing link who's here tonight the man
between tom and cbs who made it happen
and of course tom's wife kay made it
happen too who i i think maybe you knew
marcus from the hey adams hotel in
washington d.c thank you very much all
of you
thank you john
john i think
it's finished though without saying a
very special thanks to mike and to
citibank
john may be the father of uh
100 plus i don't know what the count is
now in his family but the fact that mike
set this up really tells us that the
spirit of the citibank family is still
alive and it's being nurtured by its
current father so
thank you mike for doing this
a good point
are you going to have some concluding
words well done
thank you okay
book tv is on facebook like